[Music]
today's question is from jamie in texas
dave i just blew most of my 1 000 work
bonus on my online gambling addiction
i know i did the dumbest thing possible
and i need help with this addiction
i've talked to my family about it and
they're extremely supportive but now
i've started lying about it and i feel
so much guilt
please help me so i can refocus and stop
gambling
my hard-earned money away
jamie um
you have gotten caught up in
the one of the two largest and fastest
growing addictions in america today
number one addiction in america today is
online porn number two is gambling and
it includes sports betting and sports
betting right now the height of football
season is completely over the top and
out of control if i see caesar one more
time i'm gonna shoot something
i'm so sick of these commercials but
they're making so much money off you
people you think those commercials are
free
you know why that commercial runs on
every break people because they make so
much money off you
so jamie i'm sorry i'm sorry you're
struggling with this it's a very harsh
thing
the great news is you have recognized
where you are
that you are addicted
and i'm running into a lot of young men
in their 20s and early 30s who are
losing everything to gambling addiction
right now
personal friends lost jobs marriages
you know my kids personal friends it's
it's it's wild and it's really sad
so your right to be concerned
and scared
and self-aware about the guilt and the
regret
and the sense of no control
so what would i do if i found myself in
that situation
i'm i'm not sitting here with dr john
dolone at this moment so i can't have
him chime in as a professional counselor
but i can tell you as a guy who's been
around addicts my whole life working
with them because a hundred percent of
addicts eventually end up broke
so we get to talk to them all the time
you have got to get
some people
and some processes
in your corner to help you
and so if i woke up in your shoes
uh i would go talk to my pastor and and
start having a weekly lunch with him
i would get plugged into gamblers
anonymous immediately
i would also call
a therapist a counselor
and start sitting down with a counselor
daily weekly whatever it takes
even if it costs some money because this
gambling thing is going to cost you
everything if you don't break it
it is evil and it is vicious
it is merciless what it will do to you
it will beat the snot out of you and
leave you on the side of the road for
dead dude
and so you have got to be very afraid of
the power of this over you
so afraid that you take drastic changes
and you don't worry about embarrassment
you tell everybody i'm addicted help me
i'm addicted to this help me get out of
it help me heal this addiction help me
get away from it get in gamblers
anonymous get with a one-on-one
counselor get with your pastor and
lastly get a group of friends in your
life who will bust you
not the ones who
you know are saying it's okay
and your family it sounds like when you
say they're supportive it sounds like
they've been soft
if you were in my life i would love you
so much that you would feel it
i'm gonna be all up in your stuff
because i love you so much that that's
what it's gonna take
a uh a pat on the back
and a yay raw doesn't help when you're
an addict
it takes more force
than that to move people out of an
addictive behavior
and to move them into the help that they
need to break an addictive behavior
and so it is not a it is not an act of
love to be soft
on an addict
it is quite the opposite it's borderline
enabling if not full-on enabling
so
jamie i appreciate that your family is
extremely supportive but what extremely
supportive should be is making you
highly uncomfortable
not comfortable
and the way you're saying that i kind of
think they're going oh poor jamie
you know i'm gonna bust jamie's what i'm
gonna do because i love him
and i'm gonna be all up in his stuff
and that's what it takes man you're not
gonna break something like this if you
don't
because the there's a chemistry that
goes with this there's the endorphin
release the dopamine release the high
you get when you hit
when you actually win whatever it is
you're gambling whether you're sports
betting or whether you're playing cards
or with your online gambling whatever
you're doing you get a high on it
and it keeps you coming back
it keeps you coming back and uh that's
that's the addictive nature of it and
actually we're addicted in that case to
the chemicals in our own body
um but it's not out of your control
and you're not a victim to it and you
don't have to be this way you get to
choose but you've got to put some
different people in your life and your
buddies you've been hanging out with
that think this is cool they're off
limits you got to stop it
if you have a drinking problem you can't
run around your drinking buddies
and you're otherwise you're going to
have a drinking problem duh you become
who you hang around with man you talk
like them you walk like them you read
like them you go to church like them and
you treat your wife like them
you become who you hang around with
and so
you've got to put some people in your
life that are different than the ones
that have been in your life that thought
this was okay
and that's why i'm outlining like a
pastor
ga
a good counselor
and you're gonna write a check or two
for some of this stuff but again it's
gonna be cheaper than
the gambling addiction this is the
problem
the downside
of the internet the internet is not evil
but access to porn
used to be
used to have to go to a lot of effort to
get to porn
now three clicks and you're in
four clicks and you're into stuff no
human should ever see
the access that the internet gives you
to betting
you know it's to the point that it's
like if you're not doing it you're not
cool because everybody's betting and if
you don't believe me watch the
commercials on every football game every
commercial break is two betting
commercials at least
this is tens of millions of dollars of
ad revenue
every night every time you turn on a
football game they don't give those
commercials away because by the way let
me help you with this broadcast
television has no one watching it
anymore
their ratings have evaporated
people watch on demand only
the only live television anyone is
watching is the weather report on the
local news and live sporting events
so the nfl ratings used to be the
largest thing during the playoffs and
they would beat the best sitcom on cbs
or the best movie of the week on nbc by
a few ratings points
now it's 10 and 20 and 30 x
cause no one is watching that crap if
you've turned on broadcast television
lately and you had to try to watch a
movie and all the commercials keep
interrupting you and you get pissed
that means you haven't watched broadcast
tv in a long time because that's why
it's always been
but you quit watching it and you started
watching on netflix on hulu you start
watching it and and this access
that it's giving you is is
it's devastating you guys
so the the the shift of the internet on
gambling addictive behaviors is very
real
and some of you that's your wake-up call
this little rant right here and jamie's
little problem is a whole bunch of
people's problem out there it's an
explosion of negative
consequences
and you guys have got to manage it for
your own lives you're not a victim of it